يهم الفنان الارجنتيني ماكسي بوضع اخر
لمساته على احدث لوحه لمحقق حلمهم بكاس
العالم الثالثه
ليونيل ميسي بعدما اختار لنجمه الصوره
الافضل والاكثر تعبيرا بالنسبه له اثناء
رفعه الكاس مرتديا البشتا العربيه
لانها مختلفه وتميز حدثنا التاريخي
الاستثنائي
صوري معرفه الارجنتين باللوحات تهافت
الالتقاط الصور التذكاريه معلقه التاريخيه
وكذا فعل احمد الشاب العربي القادم من قطر
والمقيم في بوينو سايرس حيث قرر ان يحضر
البشت الى المكان ويتيح للارجنتينيين
تجربته بانفسهم
خصوصا لما ميسي لبس البشت العربي قررت اني
اجيب البشت وخليهم يجربونا وحبوا الفكره
الصراحه
يعني حبوا اني يتعلمون يتعلمون الثقافه
العربيه والحمد لله قاعدين نوصلها ان شاء
الله وباموس
ايناس من مختلف الاعمار يريدون الحصول على
صوره وتجربه رداء ميسي العربي كنبات يسمى
هنا
هذا اللباس بشكل خاص يشعرني باني ارتدي
زين فاخرا شكرا لك على منح هذه التجربه
انه شيء جميل جدا
الذي خصص فقرات للتعريف بهذا الرداء
وتاريخه ورمزيته
ان في ساحه ابليسكو التي شهدت احتفالات
الفوز فكان الفنان سيجاتوري قد رسم لوحه
مع بدايه مونديال قطر 2022 للاسطوره
الارجنتينيه دييغو مارادونا بالزي العربي
الكامل ايضا
ازياء ورموز عربيه مختلفه بالوان علم
الارجنتين انتشرت المتاجر تشجيعا من
الارجنتين لمنتخبهم واحتفاءا بالاجازه
التي تعبر عن البلاد التي اقيم فيها
المونديال الذي فزنا به
منذ بدايه البطوله وحتى اخر لحظه فيها
ارتبط الارجنتين اذا بهذا الزين حيث وجدوا
في كاس العالم على ما يبدو فرصه للانفتاح
على ثقافه الخليج العربي بعد ما كان بلدهم
قد فتح ابوابه لهجره العرب من دول البحر
المتوسط منذ منتصف القرن 19 حسن مسعود
الجزيره وين سايرس